welcome back
it's a new year and it's time to set new
goals for ourselves isn't that funny how
like a calendar will give us the perfect
excuse to pull it together or make
changes i love this and our next guest
says she is ready to step into 2022
but not without a new look check this
out
hi my name is susan i'm 40 years old
and drew i need your help i need a
makeover i'm a busy mom of two and
between soccer and gymnastics i'm always
in activewear i just turned 40 and i
want to feel confident again after 16
years of marriage i want to look sexy
again for my husband you won't believe
this but i don't even remember the last
time i went to the hair salon the last
time i cut my hair it was my husband who
did it and it wasn't such a good
experience it's a new year and i'm ready
for a new susan
that is hilarious
i
i have to agree with you susan
your husband did his very best uh with
your haircut i love that you shared that
with us it's so endearing and um
i saw your video and i knew exactly who
to call for help because one of my
nearest and dearest we call her a drew
crew but she's style and makeup guru
xana roberts rossi
so
what is a good tip for us to spruce our
look up this year i think the first
thing we have to do is literally like
stand in front of a mirror
look at your body and analyze your
favorite parts like what do you really
like and then accentuate that so is it
your arms someone gonna buy more
sleepless is it your legs then we're
going to buy skinnier leggings and more
heels like accentuate the areas you love
okay well susan's husband and hair
styler extraordinaire gustavo um is in
the audience
gustavo what was the story behind the
haircut how did that happen
i mean she once uh
she wanted a new look
and
she came to me with a ponytail and can
you do this can you cut this
so i used my
uh haircut my chin
and then i tried to fix it with the
scissors
i mean it wasn't that bad
okay well are you ready to see what zana
did with your wife susan
all right here is what susan looked like
before just so we have a little refresh
in our minds and susan please come out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and look at this oh my gosh i mean i
always love drew's face my favorite
thing and gustavo's over there
[Applause]
susan
i think you look so beautiful
you can take that picture out of it all
right take it away it's gone
um okay i always ask this because it's
my favorite question
you look
stunning at 10. but how do you feel i
feel amazing really yes this is the best
way to start a year definitely
i always take
like the month of december instead of
presents and things like that i started
to think okay what did i do
what did i do this year what can i do
next year why did i want better and
actually this summer i was like i live
in new york i should go to shows and
live those things that i've never done
before
first thing that happens to me in 2022
drew barrymore invites me for makeover
so it's amazing
roxanna walk us through this beautiful
transformation i mean first off the hair
i did not do this we did not have
gustavo dude we sent her to a fabulous
salon and they chopped off literally a
foot of hair and i do think with every
inch you cut off you turn back the clock
yes
beautiful hair
and talk to me about this dress
so there's nothing sexier than a red
skin type bodycon knit dress and then
when it came to makeup dude we didn't
want it to compete like so we just kept
it really nice and natural you have the
most beautiful face and we wanted to
just bring out that structure so i'll
you know give the brows a little bit
more definition a little bit of the
flower beauty highlight on the cheek
there look at that glisten i think
gorgeous and then a wine lip it's like
simple you do not need to compete you
are so beautiful and you were shining
beautiful thank you it's so true
i definitely think you know zanna's the
co-founder of milk makeup which is one
of the best brands in the world and
i have to say
you're exactly right you chose a lip
that does not compete with the dress
well i just want to shout out nordstrom
because they are the best company
they've been so supportive of our show
here they took care of susan today but
that's not all they want to give you a
three thousand dollar gift card
[Applause]
[Applause]
and susan please have a fantastic date
night on me i want to send you to the
theater
and dinner and all you can eat and drink
and just the whole works on me for a
great night
thank you that would be great well thank
you gustavo and susan thank you and as
always
my partner in all things female
empowerment robert grassley we'll be
right back
[Music]